>>> TOPPING OUR HEALTH LEAD
TODAY, NEW YORK STATE BRACING
FOR SEVERE HOSPITAL STAFFING
SHORT ANNALS WAS TODAY IS THE
DEADLINE FOR ALL HEALTH-CARE
WORKERS IN THE EMPIRE STATE TO
BE VACCINATED AGAINST COVID OR
LOSE THEIR JOBS.
84% OF ALL HOSPITAL EMPLOYEES
ARE IN COMPLIANCE STATEWIDE, AND
THAT MIGHT SOUND HIGH, BUT IT
ALSO MEANS TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
WORKERS ARE REFUSING TO GET THE
SHOT.
JOINING ME TO DISCUSS,
DR. SANJAY GUPTA.
SANJAY, WHAT WILL HAPPEN TO THE
QUALITY OF CARE AT NEW YORK
HOSPITALS IF THE STATE SUDDENLY
LOSES TEN OF THOUSANDS OF
HEALTH-CARE PROFESSIONALS?
>> IT'S GOING TO OBVIOUSLY BE
AFFECTED.
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT
BED POTENTIAL SHORTAGES BECAUSE
OF COVID PATIENTS, BUT REALLY
THE PROBLEM, AS YOU SURVEY
AROUND THE COUNTRY IS STAFF.
WHAT HAPPENS IS HOSPITALS WILL
OFTENTIMES THEN GO ON DIVERSION,
MEANING THEY'RE NOT TAKING
ANYTHING EMERGENT OR URGENT.
REGULARLY SCHEDULED OPERATIONS,
THINGS THAT ARE NOT URGENT
OPERATIONS, THEY GET POSTPONED,
DELAYS.
IT HAS A SIGNIFICANT DOWNSTREAM
EFFECT.
WE'RE SEEING THAT IN HOSPITALS
HERE IN ATLANTA AS WELL.
THAT'S PART OF THE ISSUE.
THE MANDATE IN NEW YORK WENT OUT
MIDDLE OF AUGUST, AND THEY SAID
BY TODAY, HEALTH-CARE WORKERS
NEEDED TO BE MANDATED, AND
THAT'S WHY NTHESE NUMBERS ARE
COMING TO LIGHT IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE SHORTAGES MAY LOOK LIKE.
>> TEACHER INS NEW YORK ARE
FACING A MANDATE THAT'S ON HOLD
IN THE COURTS.
MAYOR DE BLASIO OF NEW YORK CITY
SAID AN ADDITIONAL 7,000
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION
EMPLOYEES GOT THEIR SHOTS
BECAUSE OF MANDATE.
THAT WAS THE INTENT OF THE
MANDATE AS WELL.
THIS COMES AFTER THE CDC
DIRECTOR SAID THIS MORNING THAT
VACCINE MANDATES DO INDEED
RESULT IN PEOPLE GETTING
VACCINATED, MORE PEOPLE GETTING
VACCINATED.
SO LAY IT OUT FOR OUR VIEWERS.
DO THESE MANDATES WORK?
THE HEALTH-CARE SHORTAGE SEEMS
TROUBLESOME.
>> THIS IS A REALLY INTERESTING
QUESTION, AND THERE'S DATA ON
THIS THAT PREDATES THE PANDEMIC.
THE IDEA OF HEALTH-CARE WORKERS
BEING VACCINATED MAKES SENSE TO
THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE.
IF YOU DIG INTO THE DATA IN NEW
YORK, 98% OF NURSES VACCINATED,
98% OF DOCTORS.
THERE IS A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO
MAKE UP THE HEALTH-CARE WORKERS.
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT'S GOING
WITHIN WITH THE FLU, 2019 TO
2020 FLU SEASON.
WHAT YOU FIND ACROSS THE BOARD
IS 0% OF PEOPLE VAX NATE
OVERALL, HEALTH-CARE WORKERED.
BUT A SIGNIFICANT DIFFERENCE IN
PLACES THAT MANDATED IT, HAD A
REQUIREMENT, VERSUS PLACES THAT
DID NOT.
CLOSE TO 94% IN THOSE AREAS THAT
HAD MANDATES.
70% IF IT DIDN'T EXIST.
THIS SURPRISES PEOPLE, JAKE.
YOU GO TO A HOSPITAL, YOU SAY,
30% OF YOUR HEALTH-CARE WORKERS
ARE NOT VACCINATED?
DON'T GET A FLU SHOT?
THAT'S TRUE.
THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING.
BUT IN PLACES WHERE THE MANDATE
IS IN PLACE, 90%.
IT WILL COME WITH RESISTANCE, OR
PEOPLE WHO SAY, I'M NOT GOING TO
CONTINUE WORKING IN THIS
PROFESSION IF YOU MANDATE I GET
A VACCINE, AND WE'RE GOING TO
SEE AT LEAST A CERTAIN IMPACT OF
THAT ALL OVER THE COUNTRY.
>> TODAY BIDEN GOT HIS THIRD
BOOSTER SHOT IN FRONT OF THE
CAMERAS.
DOES THE VISUAL OF THE COMMANDER
IN CHIEF GETTING HIS THIRD
BOOSTER -- IF ANYBODY KNOWS THIS
HISTORY, THE IMPACT THAT ELVIS,
WHEN HE GOT HIS POLIO SHOT HAD
ON THE COUNTRY?
>> I THINK WE'RE IN A DIFFERENT
PHASE OF THE PANDEMIC.
IT'S INTERESTING.
IN THE BEGINNING THERE WAS A LOT
OF INTEREST IN SEEING THIS.
IT WAS NOVEL.
I THINK THERE'S THREE MESSAGES
NOW.
IT'S A DIFFERENT DYNAMIC.
SUPPLY OF THE VACCINE IS NOT AN
ISSUE RIGHT NOW THIS THE UNITED
STATES.
THERE'S PLENTY OF SUPPLY.
TWO IS I THINK SEEING THE
PRESIDENT NOW GET A BOOSTER DOES
REMIND PEOPLE THAT WE'RE NOT
THROUGH THIS.
I DON'T THINK PEOPLE NEED
REMINDING OF THAT, BUT THIS IS
AN ENDEMIC VIRUS.
DOESN'T MEAN THIS IS GOING TO BE
EVERY SIX MONTHS OR YEARLY,
THERE ARE SOME VACCINES FOR
WHICH YOU GET A BOOSTER AND
YOU'RE COVERED FOR YEARS.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS WITH
COVID.
IN TERM OS EQUITY AROUND THE
WORLD, PEOPLE IN THE UNITED
STATES GETTING BOOSTERS.
THERE ARE PLACES AROUND THE
WORLDS THAT DON'T HAVE ENOUGH
FIRST SHOTS YET.
THE PRESIDENT TALKS ABOUT THIS A
LOT.
SAY HEY, WE'RE TRYING TO DO OUR
PART HERE, BUT THOSE ARE THE
THREE MESSAGES THAT STUCK OUT TO
ME AS I WAS WATCHING THAT TODAY.
>> THE CEO OF PFIZER SAYS THE
COMPANY PLANS TO APPLY WITHIN
DAYS FOR THE FDA EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION FOR THE COVID
VACCINE FOR CHILDREN 5 TO 11.
RIGHT NOW, LESS THAN HALF OF
U.S. ELIGIBLE ADOLESCENT 12 TO
18 ARE FULLY VACCINATED AGAINST
COVID.
SHOULD WE EXPECT THAT ALSO, THAT
INSUFFICIENT NUMBER FOR YOUNG
CHILDREN, TOO?
>> I THINK IT SADLY, JAKE, MIGHT
BE LOWER.
STEPWISE WHAT YOU SEE AS YOU
LOOK AT AGE GROUPS HERE FOR
VACCINATION -- IT FALLS A
STEPWISE PATTERN DOWN.
YOUNGEST AT THE LEFT SIDE,
OLDEST AT THE RIGHT SIDE.
AS YOU SAID, ONLY 50% RECEIVED
AT LEAST ONE DOSE IN THAT 12 TO
15 RANGE.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT SOME OF THE
POLLING GOING YOUNGER, 5 TO 11
YEARS OLD, YOU BASICALLY HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE ABOUT A QUARTER
OF PARENTS BEING POLLED SAY A
QUARTER WOULD ABSOLUTELY GET IT
RIGHT AWAY, AND ABOUT A QUARTER
SAY DEFINITELY NOT.
I MEAN, THEY'RE PRETTY
POLARIZING, AND 20% OF EACH OF
THOSE CATEGORIES.
THEN IT'S THE MIDDLE.
40%, SORT OF WAIT AND SEE.
THAT'S WHAT YOU HEAR FROM THE 5
TO 11-YEAR-OLD PARENTS AND ONLY
REQUIRED GOING BACK TO THE
MANDATES ABOUT 9%.
THESE ARE QUESTIONS, YOU KNOW,
POLLS THAT ARE GIVEN TO THESE
PA
PARENTS AHEAD OF AUTHORIZATION.
THEY TEND THE CHANGE AS WE SAW
WITH THE ADULTS AS WELL, ONCE
THE VACCINE IS RELEASED AND
AUTHORIZED.
MY GUESS IS IT'S GOING TO BE
LOWER.
>> DR. SANJAY GUPTA, THANKS.
DON'T MI